the military helicopter sailed through
the skies at a steady pace its
destination somewhere in southwest asia
along one of the many points where the
legendary euphrates and tigris rivers
meet depending on the outcome this
mission may have changed the course of
the scp foundation and its activities
forever or it might do nothing at all
such was often the way when it came to
dealing with the unpredictable and the
anomalous inside the helicopter dr anton
zarkov was practically rattling with
nervous excitement ever since he'd been
assigned to the 682 termination detail
after years of wasting away in an
archival desk job he'd seen the kind of
anomalies you wouldn't believe 173 that
nightmarish statue that snaps the necks
of anyone who dared to look away from it
811. the strange and also strangely
adorable swamp woman whose caustic mucus
could reliably melt seemingly any
organic matter save of course 682 itself
and dr zarkov was particularly
astonished by the aftermath of the epic
battle between 096 and 682 which left
both of these indestructible monsters
horribly maimed but all of that it was
nothing compared to what they were going
to witness today dr zarkov muttered a
prayer to himself in frightened
reverence dr clef who was sitting across
from him in the helicopter wasn't quite
as wound up like some action movie
cliche made manifest he sliced chunks
from a plump red apple with a bowie
knife and sucked the pieces off the
blade clef found zarkov's nervousness
little more than amusing first time at
site zero rookie club asked between
apple slices dr zarkov nodded forcing a
meek smile clef just chuckled
uh you're wasting your time you know
clef said everyone takes a shot at the
reptile i face it down myself once monoi
mano and during that moment i realized
something as much as it pains me to ever
throw in the towel we're not gonna kill
this thing it's just a budget sink of
course these kinds of doubts had cross
doctor's arkhoff's mind before he'd
watch countless termination attempts
organized by far more senior researchers
than himself fail and fail
embarrassingly something about signing
your name up for 682 termination was
like tying on a blindfold grabbing a bat
and stepping up to a pinata except in
this case the pinata isn't wearing a
blindfold and somehow it can hit you
back it is a one-way ticket to
professional humiliation and if you're
unlucky enough to get too close when
things go south it can be so much worse
but dr zarkov well and truly believed
that he would be the exception to so
much miserable failure after all this
was an idea nobody had tried before an
announcement over the intercom signaled
that they had now entered site zero
airspace they'd be landing shortly and
just like that dr zarkov was all raised
hares and goose flesh once again it
seemed like such a hazy distant miracle
that his project proposal would even get
majority approval from the o5 council
and now he was about to touch down and
actually see it naturally dr cleff
noticed dr zarkov's emotional cues and
like so many playground bullies decided
to seize on it don't buy into the hype
dr clef said it's really not that
special the helicopter touched down dr
zarkov felt defensive he was almost
tempted to use hard words but he
realized from dr cleff's mischievous
smile that perhaps that was always the
intention he certainly had a
reputation if one were to put it in the
most neutral terms possible but this was
your 01 proposal dr cliff zarkov
countered i would have thought you'd be
more invested in this dr clough rose to
his feet and sheathed his bowie knife as
the helicopter's side door opened he
gestured for dr zarkov to get up and
follow him before saying believe me even
a giant flaming demigod loses its luster
when you need to write enough of those
stupid reports on it the two researchers
disembarked from the helicopter and
walked into the legendary containment
facility site zero one of the most
important and secretive containment
sites out there even by the standards of
the ever clandestine scp foundation if
ever containment procedures failed here
they'd be staring down the barrel of an
unprecedented situation a patmos xk
class end of the world scenario after
all they were dealing with one of the
most serious and powerful anomalies
they'd ever contained here clef and
zarkov entered the control room filled
with huge monitors displaying every kind
of recordable metric but the largest
screens were dominated by long-range
drone footage of the iconic anomaly they
were all there to see
scp-001 perhaps better known as uriel
the gate guardian while dr clef remained
unfazed dr zarkov felt a single tear
crawling down his cheek he had never
seen an entity so utterly awe-inspiring
an impossibly tall glowing humanoid
entity with a great fiery wings and a
glowing blade made of pure heavenly fire
every bit as hot as the sun to think
that such an incredible creature existed
on the same earth as him made him feel
so incredibly small the theories as to
the creature's true nature were as
myriad as they were unknowable some of
the more devout among the foundation's
ranks even believe that he is a direct
servant of the abrahamic god guarding
the gate to paradise the garden of eden
heaven itself dr claff just laughed
everything you'd hope it'd be zarkov he
said dr zarkov nodded more dr cliff and
more even from such a distance the raw
power of the gate guardian is impossible
to ignore it radiates off of the being
like an invisible aura dr zarkov had
read all the files to get within a
kilometer of the mighty entity would be
to court death anyone who approached it
would taste the heat of its sword cleave
them apart at the atomic level and
effectively erasing them from existence
it's about as dead as anyone could
possibly be save for someone being
thrown into scp-3930
and literally removed from the plane of
existence
scp-3930 had failed to annihilate the
hard-to-destroy reptile but perhaps
where that whole lot of nothing had
failed the gate guardian would succeed
it remained floating fixed on one place
as though waiting for
something but what perhaps a fateful
confrontation with a certain reptilian
nightmare dr zarkov hoped like many he
had heard the most famous story
involving scp-001 the gate guardian
which took place before even the days of
the scp foundation after all every
foundation needs a founder doesn't it
and that's how it began the founder was
a mysterious figure no matter who you
ask some say it was 05-1 others say it
was the legendary administrator some
even believe that it was someone else
someone older someone who predated even
the current o5 council and administrator
a wise and learn figure going on a
pilgrimage around the known world in
hopes of expanding their perspective and
seeking out this strange and unusual he
was traveling down the river tigress
that the founder encountered the gate
guardian of course as always from a mile
away the founder saw the distant glowing
point shaped like a human being with
wings it was unlike anything they'd ever
born witness to that's when the founder
felt a door open in the back of their
mind and something sneak in a single
word projecting somehow infinite
authority
the very presence of the word made the
founders body rattle never had they
heard such a voice conveying such
certainty and power it had to be the
voice of the distant glowing figure it
could be anything else could it much
like dr zarkov would experience hundreds
of years later the founder even as a
person so powerful knowledgeable and
influential suddenly felt so
unimaginably small the founder became
aware of not just the extent of the
world around them or even the universe
but a terrifying multiverse of
possibilities there was light out there
of course but even more darkness and
terrifying things were hiding in the
dark is that what preparement did it
mean to be ready for all the terrible
things hiding in the dark just waiting
for the opportunity to strike just how
great was the extent of the things
humanity didn't understand out there the
founder's mind was flooded with so many
possibilities if there was a tide of
monsters in the blackness that needed to
be fought back it was too much for any
one person to ever handle the founder
needed a group all gathered around the
same mission to contain the coming
threat that the great glowing being had
warned them about people of focus
commitment and sheer willpower people
who would accept the knowledge of the
terrible things in the darkness and
still not waver in the face of their
great and noble challenge people who if
necessary would be willing to die in the
dark so that the rest of the human race
would live in the light they would be
humanity's greatest offenders even
though they would defend in secret this
was how it had all begun supposedly dr
zarkov had heard the story whispered
many times while conducting his research
into scp-001
and now here he stood perhaps where the
founder had been standing all those
years ago the scp foundation had faced
down greater threats than scp-682
the hanged king the sealed king the
scarlet king hell if they wanted to they
could go toe-to-toe with the burger king
and all of that had begun with a single
word from the mighty gate guardian
surely an ornery overgrown lizard
wouldn't be too much for it to handle
but of course they hadn't just come here
to look at the gate guardian that'd be
an egregious waste of time and
helicopter fuel they'd come here
transporting precious cargo a chunk of
scp-682's flesh cut from the beast
itself currently it was attached to yet
another remote controlled drone set on a
collision course for the gate guardian
dr zarkov watched the video feeds with
sweaty palms as he saw the drone and its
diabolical cargo enter the video's view
getting closer to the gate guardian by
the moment closer closer until the gate
guardian struck out with its great and
terrible sword for such an
astronomically huge being to move so
incredibly fast was astounding in and of
itself but what dr zarkov found even
more exciting was the result in one
quick slash of its solar blade both the
drone and the scp-682 tissue sample were
utterly evaporated gone reduced to less
than even ash dr zarkov's face split
into a manocrine if it could destroy the
tissue sample then surely it could
destroy the monster itself and what a
glorious day that would be meanwhile
back at the cross-testing chambers of
site 19
scp-682 was having another miserable day
it was dragged half-melted out of its
acid tank at 3am in the morning and left
slowly regenerating on the floor a
typical scp foundation wake-up call it
thought to itself with the role of it
still regenerating eyes what form of
horrible torment would be in store for
at this time it began scrolling through
its mental rolodex for the most recent
fail but painful termination attempts oh
yes of course they tried suffocation via
vacuum that definitely made scp-682 feel
a little light-headed at least until of
course it adapted its body to begin
releasing a gas of similar composition
to its native atmosphere which had
certainly given those white-coated
wearing sadists a lot to take note about
then how could it forget they tried
roasting it to death with extremely high
temperatures thankfully as always it had
a trick up its sleeve adapting a
carapace made of solid helium to defend
it from the fire then shattering it to
shred a bunch of those buffoons in the
orange jumpsuits then they'd cut off a
sample of its flesh shoved it into some
absurd industrial blender before shoving
what's left into a centrifuge what a
divine pleasure it had been for 682 to
hear the explosion down the hall when
the antimatter embedded in its jeans
went off and put a number of those
idiotic foundation drones in the
hospital for months serves them right to
continually meddling in the matters of
forces they couldn't even hope to
understand and today they were feeding
at the carcass of a dead cow
scp-682 sighed it felt sometimes that
the adults testing it had forgotten the
note reading highly intelligent on its
file being dragged into one of those
ghastly chambers and given some form of
novel stimulus could only mean one thing
something stupid and painful was going
to happen said stupid painful thing in
this case was that the cow was spiked
with an instance of
scp-3521 also known as the banana pill
by datto what followed was a remarkably
absurd instance even by
scp-682 cross test standards where a
huge number of bananas spontaneously
burst out of 682's body being a big fan
of bananas apparently 682 was actually
able to eat and metabolize the bananas
faster than the anomalous banana pill by
dotto could produce them and because
bananas are each individually slightly
radioactive 682 was able to synthesize
this collective radiation into a
powerful death ray that it used to cause
a great deal of death and destruction as
far as dr zarkov and the rest of the scp
foundation were concerned this thing
being cleaved apart on an atomic level
by the gate guardian couldn't come soon
enough sometimes it took the ultimate
knight to slay the ultimate dragon not
long after that
scp-682 was dosed up on enough sedatives
to give new york city a week-long nap
and carted over to site zero on a
heavily secured armored convoy taking
scp-682 this far between containment
sites was considered a matter of grave
seriousness in other words the result of
this little experiment better have been
good to justify the insane security risk
it took to even get the damn lizard out
here dr zarkov and dr clef decided to
co-supervise the cross test from the
safety of the site zero observation deck
either would have been foolish to want
to get any closer even dr clev while
undeniably a loose cannon didn't have an
outright death wish unless of course
wishing death on
scp-682 would count 682's sedated body
was strapped to a large unmanned vehicle
the kind they might use for an
exploratory mission on another planet
and sent in the direction of the gate
guardian's deadly proximal zone a
secondary camera drone was also sent in
to lag behind correctly predicting that
when the gate guardian struck scp-682
it would obliterate the unmanned vehicle
too and whatever happened out there the
foundation needed it on camera dr zarkov
had sweaty palms and gritted teeth
seeing the culmination of his
professional career unfold in front of
him dr cleff was looking at a meme on
his phone as 682 got closer it began
hearing a booming voice in its head just
like the founder had so long ago the
voice simply said one word over and over
getting louder as the unmanned vehicle
brought the two titans closer and closer
and closer
682 still feeling groggy thought oh if
it only were so simple and then it
happened
scp-682 entered the dreaded one
kilometer range the guardian slashed
down with its mighty sword creating a
brilliant flash of light in the
aftermath the unmanned vehicle was
obliterated and 682 was left heavily
injured on the ground still trying to
process what had just happened 682
looked up sobered by the pain and saw
the being that had dealt this blow 682
began to sneer is this meant to be the
garden it said before breaking into a
venomous laugh
this is not the garden the garden is far
west of here
the gate guardian struck again with its
flaming blade once again projecting that
single word
when the smoke cleared 682 was even more
horrifically injured with only one limb
left but still against all odds alive it
used the one limb to drag itself towards
the gate guardian fueled by pure rage
and spite die
you command me to die
oh wouldn't we all like that but this is
my curse for suggesting the fruit the
reptile growled back at the base dr
zarkov was mortified how could it
possibly be surviving all this the sword
was meant to cleave apart its victims on
an atomic level atomic is in freaking
adam's goddammit dr zarkov wished he had
a paper bag to breathe into dr clef
showing an uncharacteristic degree of
compassion patted zarkov on the back
saying it's okay buddy we all remember
our first time back at the center of the
action the gate guardian blasted 682
with its solar blade again somehow
despite the terrifying power wielded by
the guardian 682 continued to live it
was alive barely but after three strikes
from the sword to be alive with whatever
the evil version of a miracle would be
this is not the garden and you are not
uriel
682 roared before spitting at the gate
guardian pretender
one more violent strike from the gate
guardian and 682 finally collapsed
unconscious from the extent of its pain
and its injuries but despite all of dr
zarkov's hopes the gate guardian did not
strike a killing blow on the unconscious
beast instead it transmitted another
word another order impossible for any
human being to ignore
[Music]
as though in a trance the workers of
site zero including dr zarkov and dr
cleff entered the forbidden one
kilometer exclusion zone the gate
guardian allowed them safe passage as
they used tools and vehicles to pick up
the heavily injured
scp-682 and carted away from the gate
guardian's feet after they all came back
to their senses dr zarkov simply said
what just happened dr clef just shrugged
i've learned to stop questioning it now
go check out scp-001 the way the world
ends the gate opens and
scp-682 weighs scp foundation try to
kill hard to destroy reptile for more
madness from the two combatants featured
in today's epic video